what's holding people back from just
living in their purpose the way you've
done I think at the beginning a lot of
it is worthiness that they even can
because they don't see people around
them doing it I think this is why having
a coach can be really helpful because
when people come out and say their
dreams here's what I want to do here's
this big Vision I have for myself first
off a lot of times we talk ourselves
down from the dreams you know the next
day you realize oh my gosh I said I was
going to do that I said I was going to
start a YouTube show I said I was going
to be a coach I can't do that that's
crazy and we instantly talk ourselves
down from the thing having support
having help having a coach really helps
so it's not you just doing things all on
your own and then I think also immediate
action really helps you know that when
you get an idea trust that the idea is
good and then do something about it to
build momentum because I think we're a
lot of people the only thing they're
missing is momentum the key is like you
got to take action while you are in that
moment in that zone and what great
coaches will do is then also give you
homework to do and then you push them to
do the thing because it's in their best
interest and so I think people take 10
years to take the first step and it's
about getting momentum going because
once you have momentum it's a lot easier
to keep going but building that momentum
taking that first step is really
difficult need motivation watch at top
10 with believe Nation hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because I need them because I don't
always wake up and feel motivated to go
take on the day and the thing that saves
me that helps me every day is being
around people who are thinking bigger
who are changing the world and it gives
me a little more inspiration to go after
my mission and so I hope this video
helps you go up to yours today too so
today let's learn from me and my team's
take on my top 10 rules of success enjoy
rule number two is focus on who you
serve what kept you going
if I thought I had like 2 000 after five
years nine thousand sounds great I could
be at nine thousand
um what kept me going was I always just
focused on who I was serving instead of
who I wasn't I think the biggest problem
that we face is you make a video You
release this video I don't know how many
people end up watching this but I think
at the beginning you make a video and
like 40 people watch the video and you
feel like man I'm a total failure I
spent all that time it all that's worked
all this editing whatever only 40 people
watched it I'm a loser this isn't gonna
work
where I always thought I've met 40
people watch this thing that's pretty
dope that's awesome like imagine you're
gonna go give a speech at a library or
something and 40 people showed up you'd
be pretty excited to have 40 people sit
there but because it's online we tend to
not um make it count as much and we see
other people hitting millions and you
only hit 40 you feel like a loser so I
just always focus on who I was serving
instead of where I wasn't and that
allowed me to keep going through
um you know at the time too there wasn't
like being a YouTuber wasn't even really
a thing nobody had a million subscribers
so there wasn't even anybody to like
model or or connect with or go after but
that was always a secret and same thing
now if I'm if I'm doing
if I'm doing a speech and there's 5 000
people in the audience or five
it's like okay if we have five people in
the audience I can serve them on a much
we'll make it a round table I'll just go
around and Coach them individually
versus 5000 you're speaking to the stage
but just always focus on who you are
serving instead of who you're not really
rule three is follow momentum I love how
you like the we interrupt this book
writing to show you what I did last
night at three in the morning I think
that was really really cool because it
lets the readers kind of get into your
mindset at the time of man this guy was
he was on it all the time which I think
is really really neat oh and sometimes
you get these ideas and I'm a big
believer in following the momentum so
when you get an idea at three in the
morning what do you do well I decided I
would get up and just write I have this
thing and I know I'm not going to sleep
anyway and I could write down a couple
ideas but then I'm not I'm going to ruin
my sleep anyways like I'm just gonna get
up and write for a couple hours and then
you know go back to bed and that's a lot
of times how we get momentum is like you
you have ideas maybe you listen Maybe
people are listening to Ken right now
like I've got this idea I've been
sitting on this thing for a year and I
haven't taken any action like use this
as your permission to just start
creating the thing and you don't need to
have the perfect plan you just need to
start rule number four is stay
consistent and this is where you know
environment and habits and routines and
people around you really really matter
because people just don't stay
consistent
right because it's so easy to fall back
into our old patterns and something's
gonna happen that will you know throw
you off course and it's easy to regress
back to who you used to be it's like
it's this fight to be the person that
you want to be and it's a it's a daily
fight and there's always things that are
pulling at you to come back to who you
were and so that's where whether it's uh
habits so
you know if you say that you're going to
make YouTube videos you put in your
calendar you know and you say okay I'm
gonna make one video a week and it's
gonna happen on Thursday afternoons or
whenever it is right and you schedule it
in so even if you don't feel like doing
it you still show up and you do it
because it's in your calendar if you
wait till you feel inspired to do it
you're you're not going to do it you
know some days you'll do it some days
you won't but you won't be consistent
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is know your
priorities throughout that Journey there
had to be some kind of
perspective on the monetary gain of the
growth of the gain of growth of of that
respect was it always like I want to
serve people or how did you kind of get
past that first jump in the beginning
where I mean a lot of people aren't
really focused on serving they're just
focus on getting to a point where they
can serve uh sustainably if that makes
sense yeah so I mean I'm an entrepreneur
right I like making money you have you
have to make money if you have a big
mission if like even if you want to
serve I'm Service First like Mission
first purpose first to change the world
first awesome and you have to learn to
make money
so I I say money can't be number one but
it's got to be in your top five if
making money is in your top hundred
you're not going to make money and and
then you're just helping people on the
evenings and weekends which is still
great but it's not what you could be
doing right we've got over 50 people on
my team now
because we know how to make money if we
didn't then I'd be doing this my I
probably wouldn't be on here talking to
you because I'd have to do a million
other things in my business just to keep
the you know the thing going and so
whether you're doing
um advertising or brand deals or
sponsorships or you have a product or
service that you're selling figuring out
how you're going to make money is really
really really important especially in
the early days uh because that's that is
usually the thing that kills most
people's dreams it kills most people's
podcasts and shows like man that was so
much fun to do but I can't justify the
time doing it anymore because I I need
to make money and so I have to go back
and get a job rule number six is learn
to manage a team can you talk a little
bit about the team and and how you feel
about creating a team around you and how
that works well teams are are critical
to grow and not everybody like most
small businesses are just a solopreneur
um but if you want to scale and grow
then you have to be able to work with a
team and you have to like managing
people a lot of people don't like
managing people they like just being by
themselves but if you want to get
you want to get a return out of it and
you want to have fun
then you have to you have to want to
mentor and lead and grow and learn to
manage a team I think I think you've got
to First be connected like for you you
might not love digging ditches
uh but you got to connect to the mission
of like hey them this is for somebody
this is for somebody's home this is
we're making people healthier we're
we're helping people's lives like you
have to connect to why you're doing the
work if you don't enjoy the actual like
digging ditches or you connect to like
hey this is a good workout and I'm
getting some vitamin D while we're doing
this yeah right exactly but a lot of
people have a hard time moving from
digging ditches to then being the person
who manages 50 people who are digging
ditches
and you have to love people training
them you have to love mentoring them
like even you going and volunteering to
talk to the Junior Achievement kids
speaks to your willingness to mentor and
train and guide and and just try to give
back right that's what you have to be
doing for your team you're basically a
little further ahead than them and you
become an almost Father Figure or uncle
or older brother depending on the age
gap between young people on your team to
help them become better humans you know
the goal is they become better humans
when they're with you they're not just
collecting a paycheck rule number seven
is take a break when you're having those
days
what do you tell yourself or who helps
you on those days because we can't all
have 10 out of 10 days right like we
wish we could but they're not always
going to be attentive you have to accept
that sometimes there's a two out of ten
or a four what do you do on those days
yes so
my habits save me for most of most of
the time
um
I almost every day will have a believe
walk and and that's part of my morning
routine I wake up I got outside to go
for a belief walk and that's getting
fresh air but I'm also I'm also
listening to one of my own videos and
responding to people in my community to
remind me the thing that I'm doing
um I haven't this part's a little weird
where like I haven't wanted to quit
people's like what about quitting on you
I haven't thought about quitting ever on
YouTube uh
it's too connected now to like serving
in what I do
but do I have days that are
um lower energy or do I have days where
I'm not thinking big enough I mean
especially that one 100 you know
um yeah I think I think if you're
consistently thinking about quitting you
have to you have to understand the
reason why is it because you're afraid
or is it because you don't want to do
things I think I think people stay in
things too long like when people say
don't quit don't quit I think people
should off often quit on businesses
sooner relationships sooner job sooner
because you'll never win doing work that
you hate but if the reason that you're
quoting is because you're afraid that's
not a good enough reason
um and so where I
I am challenging myself to do the most
work is on
bigger thinking like the biggest
frustration with me is okay so if I'm at
three and a half million subscribers how
do I get to 35 right and how do I live
in that Vibe consistently
um
if I'm feeling super low energy
I'll take a break
you know like I had people over at my
house not too long ago for my birthday
I've invested into a bunch of different
entrepreneurs and I Mentor them once a
week and they came over I don't really
celebrate my birthday so like okay come
on over for my birthday and and we'll
hang out together and we spend five days
together and like all day all night fell
behind on like everything I was doing
and then I had uh the Monday where like
everybody went home kind of Sunday night
and uh like okay I'm I'm
I'm not doing anything today you know
like my voice started to get a little
sore it wasn't as like it was so much
high energy I need to I need this is
today's recovery day I think I post on
Instagram like
recovery day today I'll see you tomorrow
and I just checked out of everything
that I was doing rule number eight is
feed your mind with positivity when did
you start the habit of replacing those
negative thoughts with positive ones and
then when did you start to see them take
root and actually manifest in your life
I didn't know that I made a conscious
choice that like now I'm gonna replace
this thought with this thought I think
it's just as a result of
being in the industry so long watching
so many like if you think about what I
do and how many videos I watch of how
many successful people they all have
some core themes to them and whether
it's entrepreneurs or athletes or
artists or musicians or whoever they
have similar themes and and you know
turning lemonade they're turning lemons
into lemonade you know turning the
negative into a positive is a consistent
theme across everybody and so I think it
just it happened subconsciously just by
being in the environment of having those
people around me virtually to the point
where I was doing that exercise being
forced to sit with negative thoughts and
it I had changed but I didn't notice
like I don't there was no moment of
coming out of the Cocoon and now I'm a
butterfly it just slowly became here I
am as a butterfly gotcha so it was just
going through the process yeah it's it's
like imagine if you were working out
your legs every day okay you don't you
don't you don't see a day-to-day
difference right there's no one moment
like oh you did one extra hard set and
now you've got these Rippling calves
ready to go right
but I think the only difference was I
wasn't even
consciously training it was just because
it was in my environment and I think
that happens for a lot I think that
happens for most people just in a
negative way you're constantly watching
news and Twitter streams and all of this
negativity and all of a sudden you know
you start to become a negative person
because of all the things that are
happening around you
but it's not that you can pinpoint one
thing that that was the moment you
became negative or even notice that
you're becoming negative It's Just
Happening yeah and so that's the power
of when you shift your environment and
you're controlling what you're consuming
into your you know into your brain so I
was conscious of what I was consuming I
wasn't conscious about a lot of the
transformation that happened as a result
it's only in looking back or doing
exercises like that
um that I notice the difference I
mentioned grief as a caveat because
that's the only one that I don't think
you can
you can just positive your way out of
sure you know like I think you just have
to feel your way through grief at least
me you know I have I haven't lost my
parents so that's awesome but
um my family dog was like that was the
only time I haven't made videos in the
past 10 years is when my family dog
passed away wow uh because he died on
filming day and
I just couldn't film and I I could have
if it was anything else if I was jealous
if it was angry if I got cut off on
traffic if I lost a bunch of subscribers
I don't know something else happens like
okay come on let's go carmichaelic film
but I just didn't feel right to push
past it to film you know like I filmed
with the concussion and a broken neck
and all this other stuff but when when
Toby passed like I don't know it doesn't
feel right to just brush it away and so
I just have to feel this rule number
nine is create your own path when you
think of an entrepreneur what do you
think if you were going to Mentor a
young person what do you think the the
one or two or three characteristics that
you'd really want to see in somebody is
before you said you know what yeah I
think they're gonna they're gonna make
it happen no matter what I think there's
some characteristics to winning so a lot
of the ones that you mentioned too like
persistence and dedication and hard work
is like that is definitely needed for
entrepreneurs and they're just
characteristics of winning like you
could win and not be an entrepreneur and
have persistence and dedication and
faith and hard work I think to to
succeed as an entrepreneur you have to
want to make something different
for your life and for others because
there's there's always a path that's
laid out for you you know if you're
talking to kids like your parents have a
have an ideal plan for you they would
love for you to go and do blank in your
schools and guidance counselors there's
there's these very easy laid out plans
of what you're supposed to do
you go to school and then you go to
college and then you get a job and or or
you don't go to college and you follow
in like family footsteps and whatever it
is but there's there's very easy paths
to follow for your career where being an
entrepreneur usually means you have to
step far outside those predetermined
paths for you
and that's hard you know when nobody in
your family has done it and when you
don't have Role Models or mentors or or
you know people like you to talk to
that's really really hard to step
outside those predetermined paths and
that's what an entrepreneur is willing
to do is like not get stuck in the
grooves that have been laid out for them
when they're going to set a new path for
themselves it doesn't mean they'll be
super successful there's lots of
entrepreneurs who are below the poverty
line or like just making enough money or
or just them and they're you know
they're just getting by like most
entrepreneurs are not Mega wealthy
um but they're doing it because they
just want to create their own path for
themselves and for the people around
them and Rule Number 10 the last one
before some very special bonus clips
Chase fulfillment when it comes to
serving or just building that belief
within yourself where do you think most
people go wrong when it comes to trying
to build more belief and actually start
creating a life that you know they're
fulfilled by not just you know okay with
I don't think they're thinking about it
as much as making money
like if you if
your question like what what
mistake do people make on building a
business that fulfills them I don't
think most people are asking themselves
what would be a business that fulfills
me
like that's the biggest problem they're
not asking the question
they might be saying what's a business
that makes me money they might be saying
what's a business that maybe can have a
big impact but if you say what's a
business that fulfills me I don't think
people are really asking that question
and that's a great quarterly check-in
because the things have fulfilled you
last year may not fulfill you anymore
you've maybe you've grown past maybe
that was a fun little experiment and you
don't like that thing as much anymore it
doesn't fulfill you anymore and you need
to move on I think a lot of people stay
in the same business or same
relationship for too long because it
doesn't actually fulfill them anymore so
the biggest mistake is just not asking
the question ask the question you'll get
some good answers
we have 52 people on the team now if you
ask me how many people on my team I say
I don't know 10. and like really who and
then I look at the list like oh yeah
because I'm not in all the stuff and and
I just forget and then the next thought
was 52 people that's crazy but if I
believe that it's crazy then how am I
gonna get the 500 people and it's just
always trying to catch the language and
the thought patterns that we tell
ourselves because I think most of it is
subconscious and so whether you can
catch it in yourself or when somebody
else calls you out that you say no 52
people that's not crazy Evan three
whatever million subscribers we have
cool that's great and like how do we get
to 35 really what does that look like
nobody's done it garyvee and Tony
Robbins and Mel Robbins and Marie forleo
and Les Brown and whoever and you put
them all together you're still not at 35
million subscribers so how do I get
there and it feels impossible but as
long as it feels impossible then it is
impossible I mean I think the world's
biggest problems people don't believe in
themselves because there is no box it's
like you can just why I do what I do is
I hope that a video that I make whether
it's like this story with you or a less
Brown interview or whatever that's like
that's the moment that somebody watches
it and realizes oh there's no I could
just walk there's no door I'm not tied
to anything one of my instructors at
Toronto Dan salsa has lyme disease
also one of the guys on my marketing
team now has lyme disease but at the
time I knew nothing but like I didn't
know what it was didn't know what it
caused didn't know how you got it didn't
know anything about Lyme disease but
because she has it
I started learning about Lyme disease I
set up a Google news alert that anytime
there was something about Lyme disease I
would get notified and I started sharing
things with her that she hadn't seen
before you know started sharing that
Avril Lavigne has lyme disease and
Shania Twain had Lyme disease and they
both took big breaks from their singing
career because of the impact of Lyme
disease if there's new treatments or
holistic healing or other people talking
about it then I would I would share it
with them and I would also educate
myself in that process to the point now
where she has opened up her own Lyme
disease holistic healing practice and
doesn't teach at my school anymore she's
left the school to go launch his
business and I'm so excited for her it's
great it's fantastic right we're on the
parallel path and now she's jumped off
and then done her own thing which is
amazing now did I make her go launch
that business of course not did I have a
tiny little piece of inspiration or hope
maybe you I'd like to think so but when
you can help people accomplish their
goals
it does two things
one
it makes you feel good
you know how good it feels to help
somebody right we're all built to serve
where's the buck right there we're all
built to serve and makes you feel good
to know that you help somebody this is
what we all want to wake up and feel
like what we do matters is Meaningful
you are built to serve and so when you
can get out of your own selfish
interests and go help that person
accomplish what they want it feels good
I get more joy from doing that than than
a business transaction right I get more
joy from sending her something that
she's like oh my God I didn't know that
existed then how many views I got on my
video yesterday right it it feels weird
to know great we have three million
subscribers on my main Channel I don't
even know what that means it's hard to
even contemplate that it doesn't feel
like anything I can touch but knowing
that I helped one person with something
is the thing that gets me excited so it
feels good and the more you feel like
you're doing things that matter
at least to one person
it gives you the motivation energy to
just keep going because a lot of times
that's the thing that we struggle with
is we don't feel like what we do matters
it's not important then we lose
motivation then we stop if we quit right
so you have to feel the connection to
the work you're doing you can see the
end picture and the goal and the vision
that you've got for yourself and what
you want to make but
from where you are now to where you're
going to be it just feels too too big
too slow too impossible needing Venture
Capital funding needing a whole ton of
support like no you just need to figure
out what's the next step that will start
to pay you for what you're doing this is
where people often don't want to have
the conversation because they just want
to do everything for free
but that's great but you have to you
have to make money doing this
so that you can make this your full-time
thing so you can hire a team so you can
expand so you can have a bigger reach
you can have a much bigger impact so you
can actually create the world that you
want to create again money is not number
one but you have to figure out a way to
make money so inside of your big dream
what is the next step that you have to
take that's going to start to get you
paid
and often it's coaching often it's
selling your time right often it's
taking the expertise that you have
inside you you solve the problem for
yourself now you're going to help other
people do it you're gonna get paid to do
it everything in your life will change
when you realize that you do not want an
easy life stop praying for easy stop
praying for convenience you don't want
it because you don't want to photocopy
your life every single day over and over
and over and over again you want variety
you want change you want something
different but with that variety comes
uncertainty comes pain comes challenges
and from that pain comes purpose
ultimately your purpose comes from your
pain and the more pain you go through
the more challenges you take on the more
you stretch yourself in your comfort
zone the more you're going to be able to
reach down and help somebody come up to
your level as well you can only help
people to the extent that you have been
through something so the next time
you're going through some pain tell
yourself this is the best because it's
your chance to show yourself and the
world What You're Made Of and will
Define the impact that you will have
solve a problem
as you're talking to customers as you're
talking to people who will be using your
product or your service who will be
engaging with your content as you're
talking to these people what is the
problem that they're facing
what is the struggle what is the
challenge that they're facing and then
help them accomplish it
if I apply it to myself and the YouTube
channels for context one of the biggest
challenges I think people have is a very
poor environment
you've got people in your life who keep
you where you are some people may be
telling you that you can't do things
that's the worst case scenario some
people might be cheering you on but they
can't guide you you're not inspired by
them the people around you are not
inspiring enough for you and that's why
you're stuck because the environment is
keeping you small
where if you are around higher Achievers
if you're around Tom bilyu and Oprah
Winfrey and Elon Musk and these people
they would pull you to be better and so
that's the biggest problem that I see
the entrepreneurs that I love helping is
you know you're capable of more you've
got this big mission inside you you've
got the heart and the care and the
willingness to serve you've got
everything but you're not being pulled
forward by anybody
and so I want to try to create that
through content because you may not be
able to hang out with Tom bilio and Elon
musking Oprah Winfrey but every day on
YouTube you can hang out with Tom Elon
Musk and Oprah Winfrey from the content
that I'm going to make and create right
so that's the problem that I'm trying to
solve
and I get that because it was me who
struggled with it but also the people
that I see who I connect with who are
watching the videos they're leaving
feedback from me and I'm talking to them
and I realize you've got everything
you've got everything you you've got
everything
you're just missing that environment to
push you forward so that's the problem
that I solve what is the problem that
you solve when you can combine your
passions right step number one you're
combine in your passions
step number two is we're talking to
customers people who are going to use
potentially what we can create and then
you're understanding what their problem
is and you solve it for them
that's how we start to build a
successful business
back to the entrepreneur success formula
if you get this formula if you apply it
it's simple it's basic and it's one of
the most powerful things you can ever do
and it's the one of the biggest reasons
why entrepreneurs don't win
despite having the heart and the care
and the service you have to combine the
thing that you love doing with all your
heart with something that brings value
to other people
bring those things together and you're
on to your next successful business
career the key to enjoying your life is
being present the key to focusing is
being present the key to feeling like
you're valuable and what you do matters
is being present being present is at the
core to a lot of great things but a lot
of people really struggle to stay
present because what are you doing most
people spend most of their time
either thinking about the past
or thinking about the future and not
even in a positive way you spend time
thinking about the past living in regret
of all the things that you could have
done you could have said you should have
done you should have said I wish I did
that I wish that video I made didn't
suck you know I wish I wish I wish I
wish why didn't I and we beat ourselves
up does that sound familiar is that you
maybe even a little a little bit or we
spend our time being anxious about the
future
I think as entrepreneurs we get excited
about the future of where we could go
and what we could build and that's
that's the fun daydreaming part but a
lot of thinking about the future is
stress inducing it's anxiety it's it's
worrying about what could go wrong all
the millions of things that could go
wrong that may never go wrong but we're
still worried about them right again
does that sound somewhat familiar when
you are stuck living in the past or
living in the future you're never
obviously present but you're not happy
you're not productive you're not focused
you're not creating you're not serving
none of it and you're not fulfilled
I look at people who want to get started
on YouTube for example or entrepreneurs
are trying to launch their business
and
people made maybe one video or two
videos and because it didn't work out
you made a video and you felt
embarrassed by yourself or you launched
a product and somebody had one bad piece
of feedback if we live in that same
negativity over and over and over and
over and over again
people ask me well what happens when you
have a bad video what happens when your
video bombs I was speaking at Brendan
burchard's influencer Summit yesterday
and
somebody asked me what do you do when a
video doesn't take off or do well like
well lots of my videos don't take off
and do well I think I don't know which
ones are going to blow up the ones that
have blown up surprised me like that's
the one that blew up I love this one so
much more
how do I keep going because I'm looking
to the next one like I'm worried I'm
working on videos now I don't know what
I released yesterday or the day before
the day before
because I'm making new content
think about how you got over a
relationship well you when you get into
a new relationship it's easy to forget
about your last relationship it's
thinking about what you're doing now
and if you have nothing right now what
do you do if there's nothing to do right
now you spend your time in regret about
the past or worried about the future
it's not enough action happening right
now I don't care about videos that
failed in the past because I'm going to
be making tons more another one comes
out today and another one tomorrow
another one tomorrow and it's it's a
moment to reflect and say hey okay I
could have done better on that one or
why didn't this one do well okay this
moment here that sucked perfect I'm
making one today I'll make it better
at least that's the intent maybe I don't
achieve it but that's the intent and we
show up with that intent every day you
will eventually make it better
most people get too caught up on on the
mistakes that they made in the past it's
in the past
you did the best you could with what
you've got remind yourself of that
you did the best you could
with what you had
great don't be so hard on yourself keep
making
because the worst thing you can do is
quit now the worst thing you do is stop
now because when you look back on your
life when you're 120 that you'll regret
that you you stopped you regret that you
had a chance you had a moment
you could have done something and you
didn't like that's the biggest regret of
all
not taking any kind of action not the
mistakes that you made you we don't
regret really the things that we did
most of the things that people regret
are the things they did not do
most people's biggest regrets are not
taking enough action
letting that little man voice inside
their head
tell them all the reasons why they
weren't going to win
convincing themselves that they weren't
capable
and as a result they stopped when they
wished they had the courage the strength
the tenacity to keep going
right that could be you could you could
you could get going you keep going you
could stay present you could make the
next thing
and at the same time A lot of people are
then also worried about the future
well what if I make this and it doesn't
work out I was talking to people again
yesterday about their YouTube channels
and the same person asked me
well what if it
doesn't work out
like what if I make videos and nobody
sees them so what if nobody sees my
videos and then the next question was
what if people see my videos and they
don't like me
so this person at the same time is
afraid of people not seeing their videos
and people seeing their videos
how does that make any sense right this
is this is the loop that we get stuck in
you're afraid of people not seeing you
and you're afraid of people seeing you
you like you can't win the mental
dialogue we have it with ourselves we
can't win
that's not possible
we need to start to flip that we need to
we need to rewire ourselves
and that starts again with being present
like you can't control what the outcome
is going to be in the future but you
can't control what you're doing right
now
if you can switch so that you are mostly
present
not really thinking about the past
unless it's gratitude right if you can
flip the regret of the past to gratitude
right and if you can switch the anxiety
for the future to excitement or vision
that's when you really start to win
somebody came to an event that I did in
Toronto and asked me
these guys drove up from Boston to do a
podcast with me and then stuck around
for my event and they asked me how much
of your time do you spend
percentage-wise
living in the past present future
and I said zero percent passed
85 percent present 15 future
and the 15 percent is
is Vision what I want to create you know
as entrepreneurs we have to be a little
bit forward-thinking but it's it's 85
present
I don't even know what day it is
like it's present not even present to
today but present to this moment I don't
know what day it is I don't know what
time it is
I know what I'm doing after this all I
know is I'm here right now with you guys
and that allows for Focus that allows
for happiness that allows for purpose
that allows for life to give you so many
gifts when you're not stuck living in
the past or the future
so how do you do it how do you how do
you get there
I think the best thing you can do
is every time you catch yourself
drifting daydreaming forward or back in
a negative way
you catch it every time you can catch it
you won't catch it most of the time so
don't put this impossibly High burden on
yourself that every time I'm I'm
thinking about the past and I'm living
in regret I'm Gonna Catch and do
something about it you won't catch it
you won't catch it this is this is
Decades of un unwiring our brain right
it's fine don't don't have when you're
starting something new don't have crazy
expectations that you have to get it
perfect or you're a failure
right this is the problem not just with
this one exercise but with everything
don't expect to be great out of the gate
you won't you're just starting you're at
the beginning why do you think you're
going to be fantastic and because the
first time it doesn't work out perfectly
then we quit that is not how it works
right you you need to expect to suck at
the beginning that's okay
that's how you learn something every
time you can catch yourself drifting
you're you're living in the past in
regret or future being stressed out just
try to bring it back to right now
just bring her back to the present and
focus on anything focus on a physical
object you can you could I could focus
on my coffee like how do I how can you
get present right now you focus on the
coffee wow look at this coffee cup you
know it's tall it's red I'm I'm grateful
for the beverage inside here uh I like
that they have sleep oh it's got a maple
leaf on it right like this is all I'm
being present right now with the cup of
coffee it is warm I can feel the
sensation on my hands
I can taste it in my mouth right
where most of the time even when you're
eating something most of the time when
you're eating something you're usually
focused on something else right you're
eating while you're on your phone you're
eating while you're watching a video
you're eating while you're doing
something now so not ever actually
enjoying the food because we're thinking
about what's next
so every time you can catch it you just
try to bring it back to the moment so
right now
and then what's gonna happen is the more
you do that
the more you'll catch it
so right now maybe you catch it one
percent of the time but the more you do
that and practice that and just pick one
thing to focus on that's in your
environment or focus on your breath
right it's why meditation works so well
with a mantra or breath work because it
gives you something to focus on when
you're first starting out with being
present and focused it's helpful to have
somewhere to put your attention because
focus on nothing doesn't feel like very
practical advice to the beginner trying
to figure this out so you focus on your
breath and anytime your mind wanders
bring her back to the breath every time
you get stressed or anxious or worried
or what you're going to do next bring it
back to the breath every time you get
bored
bring it back to the breath right the
breath could be anything the breath
could be the cup of coffee look at the
cup of coffee feel the cup of coffee
every time you get distracted you're
worrying about work or your life back to
the cup of coffee back to your Mantra
right all of that can work it's just
picking something to ground you back in
being in the present
and again the more you catch it and the
more you do it the more you'll catch the
next one
and the more you're doing again the next
time
it's a skill that you learn you're
retraining your brain how to work
and what you'll find is the more you can
do that and the more you practice it
bit by bit
day by day
you'll find yourself
having less stress
being more productive
staying more focused
caring less about what other people
think about you
and overall being happier
and what that does is free you up to
actually go and do the work that's
inside you the genius that you've got
put up to the world
and serve
being present
is the key to unlocking your happy life
less time living regret about the past
less time living in the stress of the
future and anxiety for what may come
and more time focused on what can you do
right now
today in this moment
be proud of yourself
and live your best life this morning I
did my walk outside I did my yoga I did
my my stairs uh with the cold I'm gonna
try a couple things one
I'm gonna try wearing fewer layers when
I go outside it's becoming winter here
in Canada and it gets really cold in
winter in Canada so gonna try to embrace
that a little bit more and wear fewer
layers two I do a cold Splash every
morning so one of the first things I do
when I wake up is is I just put a whole
bunch of cold water all over my face so
I'm gonna keep doing that and then three
after every workout a cold shower so I
did it this morning after my yoga
workout this morning turned on the cold
the one in making sure to get it on the
backs of the shoulder this is from Tim
Ferriss that's where the the brown fat
really lives and comes alive and so
making sure you get the cold water on
the backs of your shoulder the book also
quickly mentions cryotherapy where you
stand in the machine and it takes you
down to some crazy low temperature I'm
pretty sure he said that it didn't have
a ton of research or he wasn't sure how
well it worked but he did it once so you
know what I'm gonna look into it too the
goal of this to 50-day challenge is that
how much can I do in 50 days to expose
myself to learn to get ideas to get
mentors so I'm going to also look up
cryotherapy in my town and see if I can
find something for me it is 3 24 p.m I
am officially fasting until 6 p.m
six people this is a lifesaver
hungry but you know what a little bit of
Himalayan sea salt and I'm good I'm good
these next two and a half hours no
problem we got this okay it is 6 30. I
get to eat
um we're doing a buffet for my
father-in-law's birthday so Pro side is
going to be lots of hopefully some
healthy food for me to eat Dan's head is
seeing all of the amazing other stuff
that I can't eat
but it's okay let's go
this is Nina's meal oh that looks yummy
I'm very much kind of the same way that
you are in terms of that's the biggest
fear for me is knowing like thinking
about myself getting to the end of my
life and then just wishing that I had
done this or done that or taken that
chance that one because it's a slow
bleed
hmm
can you explain what you mean by that
yeah because that regret is something
that's going to happen every day for the
next X number of years of your life like
from from now if I'm 39 to 99 at 60
years of my life right but it's going to
be a little bit of pain every day versus
doing it and failing is massive pain
yeah and so on a daily that massive pain
of failure is bigger than the little bit
of pain of regret but if you accumulate
all those days of regret and then bring
it back to today it actually ends up
being way bigger
but people don't feel it because you
just see this massive pain and you'll
pick the one you don't want to do that
massive pain right people won't do that
and so I try to make I try to imagine
myself at 99 in my rocking chair now
it's over like I can't do it I don't
have the energy I can't chase that down
my mind is going and and now that's
Decades of regret and I try to make it
more painful right right to live in that
pain moment yes and bring it back to
today so if you have a hang nail it's
going to hurt you but then if somebody
punches you in the arm you forget about
the hangnail yeah right and so what I
want to do is punch myself in the arm
with regret make it more painful so then
I don't feel this thing and so I don't
think you can be Fearless I just give
myself a greater fear right that thing
is scary failing is failing it is scary
right that asking her out or your
business tanking or whatever that's real
that's a that's a fear yeah and I just
want to give myself a bigger fear to
force me into action imagine that 80 of
the thoughts that you've got 80 percent
are negative we are beating ourselves up
we're telling ourselves that we can't do
things it's not even our friends and
family the people around us telling us
that we suck it's us it's ourselves we
tell ourselves we're not good enough we
can't do this we're not strong enough
smart enough we're from the wrong
country we look the wrong way you know
we're too young we're too old whatever
it is 80 of our thoughts are negative
and then 95 of those negative thoughts
are the exact same negative thoughts
that we had yesterday it's no wonder why
we stay small it's no wonder why we stay
stuck because we've created this
reinforcing Loop of negativity this is
why I think the world's biggest problem
is lack of belief I'm on a mission every
day wake up try to make content try to
spread the message to help people
believe in themselves more I think lack
of belief is the single biggest problem
in the world and I also believe that
everybody has Michael Jordan level
genius as something like you are the
greatest you're the greatest in the
world at something and it's not what you
went to school for and it's not what
your parents did for living probably is
something completely different and you
have to have the courage to go off and
Chase it and find it and and do it
because the woman who solves cancer
should have already solved it by now but
she never believed in herself enough to
go to medical school and now she's a
manager and accounting firm which
doesn't like her life right I mean this
is this is where most of us are stuck
most people wake up and they drive the
job that that we don't like most people
are stuck and barely hanging on and do
not like their life and feel like
they're not contributing they're not
they're not making any kind of
difference they're not doing anything
meaningful or impactful at all in the
world that's most people imagine waking
up and that's your daily reality that
may be you
or that may have been who you were and
you still describe it and try to improve
and get better but if 80 of those
thoughts that come through your head
conscious or unconscious are negative I
think a lot of conscious thoughts are
negative too
not just the subconscious the conscious
thoughts are negative you telling
yourself that you can't do something and
you're not good enough and then 95 are
the same as yesterday that we've just
created this this Loop this this
negative thinking Loop if you think
money is scarce you hoard it because you
believe that no more money will come to
you
if you know money is abundant more money
will flow to you this isn't about being
wasteful doesn't it doesn't mean you
have to go and always empty your pockets
and buy a lot of dumb stuff and throw
away all your other stuff it doesn't
mean you have to waste your money
but it's switching the mindset of money
is not just some scarce thing that you
don't know how to make that you will
never have more of and so you need to
hoard every single dollar that you've
got
this is honestly something that I am
continuing to rewire myself on I
struggled a lot with money especially in
the early days of my business
even growing up I grew up in a middle
class family my parents spent my parents
are behind me on the wall hold on there
we go this is me when I'm eight or nine
and my parents here they believed in
education a lot and they didn't have a
ton of money we weren't poor but they
spent all of their money basically on
putting the three of us kids I have two
sisters through private school so any
money that they made basically poured
into our education and as a result we
didn't have you know money for other
things and
um where my friends at these fancy
schools were getting you know BMWs for
their 16th birthday so they can go off
and drive uh you know I didn't get any
of that and it's not what was me but
it's more I just had a scarce mentality
around money in my first business I was
making 300 bucks a month I was eating
the same bean salad lunch every day
because it would fill me up and wasn't
very expensive
when we celebrated a win we'd go to
McDonald's if we got a new client like
hey we sold another piece of our
software we go to McDonald's and Order
large fries and share that between the
three of us because it was cheap and we
wanted just some little way to celebrate
and
I just remember how painful it was to
feel like you have no money and you
can't buy stuff and I couldn't hang out
with my friends and I couldn't do what I
wanted to do and I think that has a
traumatic effect you know I mean maybe
that's you as well you you have a
scarcity mindset around money that you
don't know how to make it and so
anything you've got you got to really
hold on to it and protect it
and again I'm not advocating for being
Reckless or stupid or just throwing
money away be smart about how you're
going to invest and use your money the
more important thing is developing the
mindset that you can
create money that by bringing a lot of
value to people you can make more money
you can turn it into something
so one of the things that I've done
recently that that has helped both
myself and Nina my wife is we create
what we call a care fund
and every month when we're doing our
numbers
Nina will put together how much we've
made this month how much cash flows come
in ETC and then we allocate a certain
percentage for a care fund that we have
to go off and spend
either for ourselves or for other people
and so my default is to invest invest
invest invest invest right like invest
back into the business invest into into
into markets invest in the assets just
invest invest invest invest invest
invest
the and that's a good that's a great
good mindset the downside of that is you
don't get to see
the impact that it can create
and so said you know what we need to
dedicate a percentage every month to go
and help somebody else and maybe it's
help ourselves you know
um on the weekend Nina bought a very
expensive purse
we went shopping she had a very
offensive purse we bought a Chanel bag
and
probably more expensive than she's ever
bought a bag and for me it's like oh my
gosh you can't be spending this amount
of money on a bag
but it's worth
celebrating yourself so you know what
like we earned that we did so much work
in our business you can you can go and
afford that
we've also used the money to donate the
Charities we've also used the money to
support our family and things that they
needed or wanted in their lives and it's
something that we have to spend every
month
Nina asked hey can we just save it so we
can invest more and then that leads to
more in the future like no we're already
saving other money to do that like that
has to be spent every month and so where
we have to sit this might sound crazy we
have to sit down every month and figure
out how we're going to spend this money
because my default is not to go and
spend the default is to invest or just
to save
and so doing that it doesn't have to be
a big amount of money it could it could
be a hundred bucks a month that you
force yourself to spend on making
somebody else's life better or even your
own like that thing that you would never
buy for yourself you know what I've
worked hard like I'm gonna buy it or
you're gonna go buy somebody a meal or
you're gonna go and give a homeless
person a hundred dollars right like
you're gonna you're gonna do something
with it
because what it does it starts to change
your mentality around it it starts to
make you feel like
more will come
that I'm creating
and so whether it's 10 bucks 100 bucks a
thousand bucks 10 000 bucks like you
know whatever it is I'm not advocating
you go drain your bank account and just
go crazy and buy a Chanel bag you know
but allocating a certain percentage
every month
so that you can start to rewire your
beliefs around money that it's not just
super scarce so that would be step
number one right allocate some kind of
budget to helping especially others
because when you can when you help
others it just makes you feel so good
and you can help others in a lot of ways
you can help them with your time you can
help them with your expertise you can
help them you know not just give a man a
fish but teach them how to fish right
but there's there's the immediate
gratification of helping somebody buying
the coffee for the person behind you in
line or seeing somebody that you know
that that
25 bucks 100 bucks will make a big
difference and like you were able to
afford to do that
gives you the extra oomph to go off and
want to do more of it like if you know
that that 25 bucks change that person's
life imagine if you can give them 2500
bucks
but to do that you'd have to go off and
build a bigger business right so the the
core of your business needs to be
serving and helping and contributing
back and you can't afford yet to give
somebody 2500 bucks but you could if you
kept building your business and so it
just gives that little extra bit of
motivation and incentive right to get
out there and start to do it to allocate
a certain percentage second is to be
around people who are
who are generous be around the people
who have the mindset that you want to
have if there's a belief that you want
to adopt the fastest way to do it is to
be around the people who constantly are
screaming that belief the people who are
constantly living that belief so if you
love
my view on something great hang around
me more often there's lots of videos you
love Grant cardone's view or garyvee's
view or Oprah's view on something the
more you hang around them and watch
their content and read their books and
listen to their speeches the more you're
going to start to adopt that same belief
system
so if you want to believe that money is
not scarce then you need to be hanging
around people who believe that money is
not scarce because probably the people
in your life believe money is really
scarce and the people that I grew up
with believe that money is really scarce
the closest people around me and so it
doesn't mean you stop hanging out with
them but you need to inject new people
in even if it's just through YouTube
videos
are the people who believe the thing
that you want to believe because
otherwise you get pulled back down
because your environment has been
created to keep you where you are so if
you want to change where you are you
have to change the environment and it
used to be that you had to you have to
really change it you have to go
somewhere else you had to move out you
had to find a mentor to hang out with
and have coffee with consistently now
you can do it through through YouTube
I've been inspired by tons of mentors
who have never met
because of the content that I've learned
from them on YouTube
but it takes the effort and intention to
be consistently around it that this is
the belief system that you want to have
you need to create that habit for
yourself from the things that are on the
wall to the clothes that you wear to the
media that you're consuming every day
being intentional with that to say this
is this this is the belief system that I
want to have I recognize I'm not there
yet but this is this belief system I
want to have and I want to be around the
people who believe this to their core
because their belief in that thing is
stronger than your belief against it
and whoever's more confident wins
and so when you're around the people who
believe that thing so much they will
pull you towards them to start having
that similar belief system and then
everything starts to change
I think having a scarcity mindset is
extremely limiting
I've I've lived through really intense
versions of it I still feel like I'm
coming out of it I've grown a lot
compared to where I used to be but still
have a lot a long ways to go I probably
still have things
that I'm holding on to that I shouldn't
I probably still should be more generous
than I am
um and I'm I'm working through it as
well I might just be a little bit
further ahead on the curve definitely
compared to 19 year old Evan who thought
money was the most scarce thing in the
world
when you can learn to make that rewiring
happen that's how you start to change
your life
so if you look at the people around you
look at their beliefs especially around
money
and see what do they think and then see
where they're at in their life compared
to the people who have different beliefs
around money and where they're at who
would you rather be and you could be
there you could be that person
if you start to change your beliefs your
environment start to
help more people with it start to allow
the money to flow because when you start
to believe that you can create a lot
more money for yourself
a lot of things start to change
everything that you want out of life is
on the other side of your fears every
great thing that you want out of your
life the the life you want to create for
yourself for your family for the
community for the world the life that
your family and you deserve is on the
other side of the things that you are
afraid to do and if you never jump into
it if you never address them if you
never do those things those great ideas
that you got inside your head that could
change the world if you never take them
on
you'll live your entire life knowing
that you you were capable of more
and each played small you might have
convinced yourself of all the reasons
why you can't do it but really deep down
is just fear and you played small and we
need to change that in this video
I just uh came back from doing an event
this weekend
who's virtually uh where I spoke in
front of a couple thousand people
and just before going to speak
my niece was in the other room and she
asked me hey are you nervous
you nervous about the speech you're
about to give I didn't have any slides I
was set to speak for almost an hour
and I had one or two thoughts that I
wanted to make sure I got out and
I just wanted to jam with the audience
my favorite thing to do wasn't just to
give a prepared speech but to try to
bring as much value based off of the
people in the room and get their
questions and answer them and so she
said aren't you nervous doing that live
uh with no slides like are you nervous
like yeah I'm nervous
and I do scary things
if you look at your calendar for the
next month look at it look look at what
you've got booked your next calendar if
there's nothing in there that scares you
I believe that you hate your life
that just means that you're you're doing
the same thing over and over and over
again right you're photocopying your
life over and over and over and over and
over and over every day is the same if
there's nothing in your calendar that
scares you everything is the same people
ask me all the time they message me and
say how do I remove the fear how do I
get rid of all the anxiety like well you
don't all the way
having too much anxiety sure but you
don't want a life with no stress with no
anxiety with no uh with no fear that
means you're
repeating the same day over and over
again you would hate that life you'd be
bored out of your mind you'd be bored
out of your mind so you don't want that
life
the key is we're not attacking it we're
not addressing it you're not doing
enough to to jump into the thing and so
you're just reliving the same fear in
your head of what could happen over and
over and over and over and over again
the path through fear is through
it's not to play small every time you
get scared of something and you don't do
it you're teaching yourself to have less
self-confidence
if something if a great idea comes to
you
maybe get a good idea from this video or
or another video or a book or a friend
you get inspired a great idea comes to
you and it's a big idea and it's going
to require you to grow and be a better
version of you right
and then you don't do it you play small
you find some excuse some reason why you
can't do it
what you're doing every time that
happens what you're doing is you're
teaching yourself that you play small
you're teaching yourself to have less
confidence in yourself less belief in
yourself
that you're not capable you're teaching
yourself in these moments every time
that you're not capable of doing these
things
I'm somebody who can't do this that's
what that's even if you don't say it out
loud that's what you're teaching
yourself every time that you play small
and you don't do the thing
you need to start to flip it
you need to start to show yourself that
you do difficult things that you take on
challenges that you jump into the fear
whether it works out or not is not the
issue whether you get the result or not
is not the problem is did you try did
you put your best effort in
foreign
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome pretend more amazing rules from
garyvee check the video right there next
to me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there your
grandfather podcasts lean into
positivity then eyes wide open and is
this delusional and lacks practicality
like you know if I just dream it it will
happen no lean in cut out